thank you
[Music]
so since since Tim's here you know uh we
wanted to do pro-gay day because we're
all
yup shout out to the game this has been
a very very Monumental time for
Singapore oh I just saw I saw that it
did there it is you get killed to be gay
all the gays to Sentosa
specifically uh end of Singapore's gay
sex ban in general so you can't be uh
you can't have gay marriages yet I say
yet because who knows where High Hopes
huh yeah but there was a death sentence
were they enforcing that
the thing is I think people weren't
really enforcing it in the last few
years because I think that's one very
difficult and then Singapore was
obviously behind compared to like a lot
of other like you know Western cultures
and blah blah blah that we're posting
but uh this is considered a colonial era
um rule which is I think the uh it's
377a the law I just didn't like that
booty [ __ ] huh something like that I
think 377a yeah the Prime Minister
didn't seem excited though he was like
he was like so you it's not illegal
anymore
but he's like God damn it you still
can't chew gum here I don't care what
the [ __ ] y'all do drinking anything on
the MTA bro how do you even catch
someone doing booty sex that's true like
that's the most difficult thing it's
already it's not the only thing gay
people do dog no but gay sex
well maybe I mean L7 or just catching
someone in there maybe maybe it's
entrapment like he's got to be
undercover cop and then flirt with a
dude right when he puts it in gotcha
just come when he puts it in it's an
inside job then you gotta cover yourself
fire I didn't mean it that way at all I
didn't know there was a pun there but
fire thank you I appreciate it
two dudes check into a hotel and they
only ask for one bed and then maybe the
cops come out oh yeah no that might be
the actual thing because isn't it in
some like Saudi like air like countries
you can't check you can't book a hotel
with you if unless it's the girl with
you is your wife interesting really yeah
it could be yeah some places where you
really can't you gotta like show a
[ __ ] proof of marriage would you like
two twins like no just have one king
you go to jail [ __ ]
I went to a hotel in Vietnam and um they
said that if the person didn't check in
with you prior to 10 pm
a female then you can't have her here
they don't want the hookers to come in
that's lame yeah they don't live dude
yes facts let the prostitutes do their
thing don't do the thing don't hurt
anybody there's a culture of everything
like shouldn't people just be [ __ ] in
like the morning or something you know
it's just the process get the early [ __ ]
yeah you picked them up earlier check
them in and say I'll hang out with you
later and then that's you know
everything has a loophole was the Prime
Minister really disappointed when he
looked like to me it looked like it but
he could just be being an Asian dad you
know like fine you can go to say the
Hopkins
it's like one of those weird things
where it's like under the covers like
his son or something like that yeah yeah
so he's like [ __ ] now we have to change
the legislation what the [ __ ] these
singaporeans love you I love it because
we're all not really sure what to do oh
it's like Chinglish right yeah they end
everything with a lot yeah we have to
change the legislation they're so close
did you know that the uh first like the
main language in Singapore is English
yeah yeah that's tight I always tell
people like yo if you need like a a
first trial Asian country go to
Singapore is the best one yeah no that's
not first Charlotte again I've said this
many times Singapore is the wakanda of
Asia you can't go to like wakanda and
then be like check out the rest of Asia
no but it's all gonna suck out no it's
perfect because it sucks it's the
wakanda everyone speaks English it's
[ __ ] clean the food is fire and it's
cheap I would say a better entry point
to actual Asia of that same nature in
South Korea word
where English isn't necessarily the
first language everyone speaks user
friendly yeah very user friendly I will
say the same thing about Thailand
because Thailand
um they genuinely love foreigners as
opposed to I feel like other Asian
countries they might just like you
because you're a tourist and they're
trying to get your money Thailand is
kind of legit they're like yo
let's [ __ ] party yeah
I've never been in Thailand
I know what are you going to talk about
I'll go with you I'll let you know
um it's gonna be like you know I won't
no it'll be good it'll be with me
family so probably not oh man so
Singapore's decision to lift the
colonial era ban on sex between men is
long overdue and will not end
discriminate uh discrimination of LGBT
groups in the conservative city-state
rights activists and members of the gay
community said uh this past Monday the
announcement by Singapore's Prime
Minister
reluctant announcement to repeal the
so-called 377a law on Sunday came as he
also said the government would take
steps to prevent legal challenges that
would allow same-sex marriages to be
recognized
what is the
so what is the reason is it religious
because the prostitution is legal in
Singapore so it's like what is pop into
it exactly is it popular oh yeah yeah I
mean I've heard yeah it's confusing
three floors of [ __ ] yeah we stayed
there we did all right
be my family you and your family stayed
at three floors of horror yeah dude it
was great I heard that I heard the food
is popping well I think there was a
bunch of like food spots around there
but we didn't he's like I don't know
about the food dog I was [ __ ] hoes
yeah my whole family was just a specific
Hotel
I well I think well if it's the same one
I'm thinking of yeah because it's called
like Orchard Plaza yes yeah that's the
one we were at we were staying in there
well because there's a
but Sully their great name so like
regular people and prostitutes they just
intermingling we're just walking through
the Halls dude sharing elevators really
good wow that's awesome fine ass
prostitutes in like Malaysia and I was
like damn who are those girls and then
remember Genie boy remember Ginny boy
um the radio show guy no oh I thought
every YouTuber knows him but anyways he
was like
oh they're not girls
oh because it would be weird I was like
oh [ __ ] really it's true man Asian dudes
make the hottest girl let me tell you
something Thailand
it's beautiful transgender you've ever
seen it look when I was 10 years old my
dad took me to this room that's the
dangerous number
please when I was 10
me to this really famous show in
Thailand called Alcazar and he was like
it's like all Showgirls right my dad's
like what do you think of these women
you think they're pretty I'm like oh
yeah super pretty he was testing you're
getting this song I guess so
um and he's like those are all men I was
like oh
and then I took my dick out my little 10
year old dick out immediately I started
now
but he was like those are all men I was
like oh [ __ ] but it's just it really is
a part of like Thai culture you know I'm
saying and like uh they do it we do it
the best there's more uh history have it
down yeah they've been doing it for
longer yeah man especially when it's
competitive like that mm-hmm there's
like no there's no homophobia there
right I mean I feel like but this this
uh for sure this older generation is
like we'll make jokes about it but I
don't think it's ever a situation where
they're like attack somebody you know
what I'm saying because it's such a part
of the culture for so long you know what
I'm saying ever since my dad was was
young you know and probably beyond that
this is the show you watched Alcazar
Alcazar yeah those are all uh you know
used to be Menses or maybe they're still
Menses who knows look at that so it's
not a drag show it's like its own thing
it just looks like a pageant like it's
their own thing it's all and they're all
like transgender I don't know if they
like uh are pre-op or post-op or what
the situation is downstairs but yeah all
these dudes are fine thanks
just made Shen Yoon a little more like
that I'd go dude dude menu dude
I gotta go to a shenyon show now because
I [ __ ] see it
a dog it's weird don't do it it's
[ __ ] weird bro it's weird really yes
yes yes it's so weird so me and Rick
were like was it weird because it was
Rick no no no it was we went so we went
they were they they had a show in Long
Beach is it a propaganda show yes okay
it's so funny that you and Rick went
together we were determined we were like
whatever whatever this [ __ ] is we're
gonna go [ __ ] watch it because it's
on every billboard yes okay so first
it's like okay this is just your regular
like you know Vegas like dancers and
pretty costumes you thought it was like
a Chinese Circle yeah pretty much right
and then
they start to do [ __ ] dog it gets a
little it gets a little crazy right the
head Colonel Sanders no no no no no no
no so well we didn't stay for the second
half first half we were out that's how
bad it was yeah because okay not gonna
lie even the cultural [ __ ] it's pretty
but it gets a little boring like we were
nodding off oh yeah dude off right but
then they start to do this like so it's
like it'll be [ __ ] where
um so they love this thing they do it's
like a background where a care a live
person will jump off and then on the
background screen someone will fly like
into the [ __ ] like Wilderness and
like the stars and [ __ ] they did that
like 20 times bait and switch first time
I was like oh a second I was like all
right we get it guys you have a screen
yeah we get it so and then it starts to
be like a guy came out and he starts
singing right but the translations are
like you know
um join this person and they will like
the universe and they will take you to
the heavens and the universal like all
this [ __ ] it gets very like religious
right almost cultish almost you know
you're not really sure what's going on
and then the propaganda [ __ ] kind of
starts to come in with it okay there was
this like skit right where this guy
he works for some like government and
like it's China right he works for China
for some government say which specific
country and his like he's supposed to go
after people that go against the
government or whatever and then this
girl like gets her like one of her
organs stolen from her I don't know if
it's her harder for her kidney or
whatever this is all a [ __ ] skit
right and then he finds out oh my God
it's his daughter okay that's the twist
oh wow and then but then and then she
comes back to life because
she she joins whatever religion the
shin-young is pushing yeah and then it's
like and then I'm like come all right
bro don't tell me they're gonna say this
is like then someone comes out they're
like this is based on a true story oh my
God what is this oh no it gets a little
crazy bro yeah yeah well yeah how could
I not you know what I'm saying so uh I
have coupons for you guys if you want to
go let's all go can you use like a Time
Sheriff you just made me want to go even
more go go for yourself because you know
the kind of Comedy I like uh yeah and
that's when you left after that so so
then they had the intermission after the
first act right so would you like to
join no they didn't do all that but
someone's you know there's an announcer
that comes out after like every act like
it's a girl and a guy a white guy and an
Asian girl and um it's definitely like
man is the white guy speaking Chinese no
no he's speaking English
yeah she's like doing the English side
and he's like doing the Chinese he just
has a bad Chinese accent but it's all
fake
but yeah after the first acne and Rick
were like all right Miss let's get out
of here but I just let you leave yeah
they don't like change I would love it
in the audience like was it a bunch of
white folks what was it it was it was
everybody because you know everyone who
has seen these like constant commercials
you're curious about this here right but
I definitely saw like the more like I
felt like I saw this like very religious
black family as they saw the very
um religious undertones were kind of
like oh what what is this yeah were they
like this is not Christian like that Pro
well you know I mean any when you go to
a really Christian School
everything that's like says it talks
about anything like that is like okay
this this is not of God you know what
I'm saying and I can feel them we're the
Chinese yo-yos yeah right I would have
loved Chinese yeah but even that [ __ ]
got a little boring you know yeah no
Chinese yo-yo so with a plate
where's that 50 Chinese dude on a
[ __ ] tricycle Dude Where's the
Greaser from Ocean's 11.
[Music]
foreign
[Music]